welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and spider-man homecoming starring
Ironman was the MCU bro-hug that brought
tears to our eyes infinity war an
endgame as a movie I have rewatched for
Easter eggs before including winning the
directors Howard the Duck Hunt I was
blown away how many overlooked visual
details were still hidden throughout
this great great film so many subtle
connections to the Avengers so many cool
visual details
there's no time we had a die did okay
the film opens on the kids drawing in
the battle in New York reflecting how
this film is a youth view of the MCU
down to Hawkeye Katie Mike Wazowski
Adrian Toomes and his crew clean up the
Chitauri Tech in Grand Central at the
foot of Avengers tower including and
this same row of eyghon that Thor and
Hulk took down Toombs Hulk's out on the
damage control guy maybe next time don't
overextend yourself what you say yeah
he's right i overextended myself yeah
whistling there was Bryce who later
makes the same mistake with Toombs and
gets a whistle signaling his ko I'm just
saying maybe your wife would like to
know will you really get your money from
we jump eight years later which Marvel
authorities later confirmed was a
mistake this prologue is set in 2012 and
right after savour would be four years
later exceed I think the original
version of the prologue had no time jump
title at all since that's a weird thing
to do before the mean title anyway but a
last-minute studio node's worried
audiences wouldn't get the timeline
leading to this rushed last-minute edit
with novak checking tombs vulture body
armor is the salvage Tatari armor that
we saw on Hydra soldiers in age of
Ultron making him a scavenger of
scavengers the ultimate vulture persona
and later his helmet hair inflate jacket
evoke his comics look see both the
villain and hero of homecoming are
self-made really embracing the classic
DIY soul of Peter Parker his star tech
suit is overpowered that's the point
deep down it's a coming-of-age tale from
toys to tech and Peter wins ultimately
because he becomes the more responsible
self-made hero Michael Giacchino once
again composes the music he introduces
avengers tower with major chords
[Music]
and then he inverts it to minor chords
with Toombs
[Music]
it's time we change to to hint at the
Avengers dark consequences chiquinho
also adapts the 60s Spiderman animated
series into the orchestral theme over
the titles
Peters travel video includes a shot of
the World's Fair a callback to the stark
Expo in Iron Man 2 which was later
retconned to be Peter Parker's first
appearance in the MCU Robert Downey jr.
's name in the end credits features arts
that recreates that moment after the
Civil War airport battle happy and Tony
drop Peter off at the Stork internship
retreat
everyone was impressed come on
see happiest is hoping to get bumped up
to asset management he was for head of
security Tony's for head of security Joe
calls back Iron Man 3 this is for head
of security and notice that the stick is
before happy honked Peters eyes darted
left and unlike Tony Peter doesn't jump
at the honk a little example of Peters
spidey sense
he saw that near crash ahead of them
happy also struggles with Peters heavy
suitcase yet Peter carries it no problem
and we switched from the point of view
of home video to objective framing right
on the key reveal here happy can you
give us a moan
you want me to leave crap Peters case
out of the trumpet I can keep the chute
this transition blocks in our picture of
Peter Parker still learning the
responsibilities of toys versus tech and
the value of being self-made that's not
a hug and just grab the door for you and
of course an end game those two Avengers
finally get there Peter sticks to happy
include House Black Widow or should I
say Natasha and another one about
quitting marching band which Tony later
uses to catch him in the lie I'm at bad
practice that's odd happy told me you
quit band six weeks ago so they were
eating these also notice the tiny crack
and Peter screen each time we see his
phone throughout the movie the screen
gets more and more damaged showing
Peters increasing threat level and
forming a spiderweb a crack the midtown
Morning News it's hosted by Betty Brant
name of The Daily Bugle Betty Brant from
the comics and Jason Aiello a friend of
Flash Thompson the comics we also meet
Flash Thompson whose license plate reads
flash drive huh little clue that the
plates in this movie are definitely
worth looking at the school's mural
shows Howard Stark and a photo of Bruce
Banner it's among the famous physicists
in the classroom there's an extra who
briefly looks the camera
and Peter goggles Liz I'll knock out the
basic bones of the deaths are on my
place and and then I'll come by after
the app Peters tuning out Ned telling
him when he's gonna come over later
which is why Peter forgets Ned would be
in his room and accidentally outs
himself idiot
Peter answers a problem about the
physics of pendulums signalling that
this guy's constantly calculated his
swing trajectories when he's on the
streets also on the cargo plane later he
applies quick thinking jet propulsion
physics in order to turn the plane nerd
YouTube video he's watching is uploaded
by rocket Robinson 67 which is a real
YouTube channel created by the
production with BTS videos including a
mention of a rival school with the
Asgardian mascot the girls basketball
team takes on the Flatbush as Guardians
this Thursday night Midtown mascot is
the Tigers a nod to Mary Jane's classic
and go get him tiger to Peter Parker in
this video URL is actually the same URL
of the second homecoming trailer that
dropped months before and on the
recommended bar there's a video up next
Allen tutorial a great channel with
surrealist how-to videos a bunch of
short poems from waverly flam's
director John Watson why you filmmaking
group Peter mixes his own web fluid it's
labeled 3.0 one may be a nod to this
being the third live-action spider-man
is academic decathlon group includes
Michelle later revealed as MJ Cindy moon
aka so chroma comics and slide by mr.
Harrington whom Kevin Feige confirmed
was the same character as martin stars
grad student and hulk peter awkwardly
changes into a stark suit which vacuum
seals to shrink wrap around him so he
could have worn his clothes under it but
i guess he didn't want the lumps or the
awkward movement actually the next big
question will break down the more
awkward elements of peter suits and lots
of superhero suits check it out but
notice that after webbing his backpack
to the dumpster
garbage juice spills all over it peter's
bike sign text place that forces his use
of a - as he does later on tomb sign
remember kid spider-man is hyphenated
except in the titles of some of our
youtube videos to go to the stupid Algar
that makes it harder to find if we push
weight properly when he helps the lady
who later gives them a churro behind
them is the churro cart but they get it
from Stan Lee cameos and they over the
boombox is a cameo from the train punk
and Star Trek for the voyage home Peter
stops ATM robbers with Avengers masks
like the moment the Ultimate Comics
are your the Avengers what are you guys
doing here Thor and Hulk weren't in
Civil War so Peter didn't meet them and
he has Thor punch Hulk payback for
Hulk's punch and Avengers behind Peter
is assigned for identity theft like the
Robert stealing the Avengers identities
here now they used the anti-gravity gun
and Peters and his grappling rips up the
floor tiles and he follows the
screenwriting adage save the bodega cat
you know while Peter was in that bodega
one way to bounce back would have been
swiping a can of bang energy thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces then it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
sugar free that's zero calories yet it
tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from one of those
great flavors is bankster berry which
berries he might ask the bankster ones
but the most delicious ones as well see
there are mornings when I was up late
the night before or writing a full movie
breakdown and I'm really dragging a can
of bang energy helps pick me up so I can
you know bang stir my way through more
work well you get the idea they have
caffeine free beverages for folks
sensitive to caffeine or want to drink
one at any time of the day
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at bang - energy calm
when you use the code new rock stars 25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best bang self thanks again
to bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25% off at bang - energy calm using
the code new rockstars 25 so when Peter
calls happy the graffiti behind him
reads Bagley a nod to Mark Bagley the
comic book artists who worked on a
number of spider-man issues happy
Antonis dummy robot clear out the tower
because it is sold now in far from home
the tower is remodeled with an atrium
many suspect the new owners could be
Reed Richards remodeling it into the
Baxter building of the Fantastic Four
and then see you Peter collect Star Wars
stuff including the 8080 at both alright
let's leave it at that showing how he
thought of the Empire tow cable trick in
Civil War beside the tight place is the
Korean Church of Asgard and interesting
in the news footage shows a file photo
of spider-man coming out of a porta
potti in far from home a fan actually
prints this out for him to sign
Ned pesters Peter about his powers can
you spit on them can you summon an army
of spiders no Ned yeah spitting venom
may be like Peter in the comics symbiote
spitting off him onto Eddie Brock there
is also a comic where at Peter summons a
spider army and he probably got the
teacher lecturing about the sokovia
accords of war and Ned mentioned
standing on a Ledge and shooting the web
as far as he can like the Toby McQuarrie
spider-man but who knows what that girl
in front of them fact they were talking
about
yikes they watched the Captain America
fitness challenge my fourth favorite
kept America film pretty sure this guy's
a war criminal now but whatever
after Saudis video described out of
state let's do it earlier this gym
teacher chatted with principal Morita
Kenneth Choi who also played his
grandfather Jim Morita caps Howlin
commandoes buddy here's a photo of Jim
Arena in his office along with his
medals and dog tags
so I'm guessing Murray does on team cap
and wants to keep showing these videos
cap actually shows up in a detention
thing video later and in the second post
credits scene and all of these he's
wearing his 2012 Era suit suggesting he
recorded these between Avengers and
Winter Soldier when he was at the peak
of his Boy Scout unwavering patriotism
the girls have a totally normal
schoolgirl chat you see for me it would
be F Thor Mary Iron Man and kill Hulk
mmm well after what Hulk did to Harlem I
don't blame them an spider-man being
burned under the mask it's kind of a dig
at Deadpool whose face is scarred under
the mask from Weapon X you look like an
avocado had sex with an older more
disgusting avocado Aunt May's car
license plate reads eight and f-15a not
too amazing fantasy 15 Spider Man's
first debut in Marvel Comics Peter foils
Bryce's arm deal with Aaron Davis Donald
Glover one of the many community cameos
in the MCU and voice of the animated
Miles Morales now this is crafted from a
reclaim sub Ultron arm straight from
sokovia and I'd
black Hogan aged get I grab climbers
yeah his weapons are from the Ultron
sentries and black hole grenades are
from the Dark Elves and dark world but
Aaron is under the climbers and not to
his Prowler identity and Bryce's shocker
gauntlet was crafted from crossbones
gauntlet and Civil War Peter slides in
her car with the plates ASM 267 a nod to
the amazing spider-man 267 on which
Peters in the burbs we get a Ferris
Bueller reference and the vulture grabs
him briefly framed in the moon creating
a Batman logo for Michael Keaton's past
role in Tim Burton's films he also
played the Birdman guy loves wings
Peter's saved by the Iron Man mark 47
upgraded from the broken mark 46 of War
its remote control - notice how it
continues to mirror Tony's gestures as
he's talking remotely from India Tony
shows how a suit has a tracker chip in
heaters the latest example of how Tony
makes upgrades - picks past mistakes
Peters after nearly freezing to death in
Iron Man 3 a locator chip after
misplacing Ultron on the DC trip their
school bus passes a roadworks sign
mentioning Triskelion cleanup referring
to the project in sight wreckage from
Winter Soldier tombs crew actually
brings it up again along with Lagos from
Civil War oh that's so cool they're
still cleaning up their Triskelion mess
and in a deleted scene their bus
actually passes the Triskelion with a
Helicarrier crashed into it they're
still cleaning up Foreman Captain
America tick down the sky
I'm pretty sure cap was just ripped to
save us from tyranny
that's what don't you Peter also answers
the trivia question strontium barium
vibranium what are two actual alkaline
metals in an Easter Egg fictional one
knit as a laptop sticker for the
subreddit our PC master-race
true guy in the chair tomorrow's rogue
theory will actually explore which
characters in Peters orbit Ned flash MJ
Mike had adapted a new spider heroes or
villains in future films be sure to
check it out Peter's suit AI named Karen
is voiced by former Betty Ross Jennifer
Connelly who in real life is married to
Paul Bettany who before vision played
the less robotic AI Jarvis the heads-up
display shows how much Levy and his
shooters have depleted and that number
ticks down throughout Peters hours in
the suit and here he deactivates instant
kill buddy ins a using an end game in
the vault Peter finds this metal ring
this was actually the turkey that Ultron
rigged to drop zoocobia there's also an
Ultron head with its eyes glowing red
which in that movie did signify when the
century contain Ultron's consciousness
possible clue that Ultron lives and we
are still living in his age Peter tests
out his ricochet web and web grenade
which along with the Taser web are all
functions he uses later ricochet web to
catch the elevator web grenades on the
ferry and taser web against tombs Peter
runs past the same reflecting pool where
a cap laps Sam a Winter Soldier and it's
Washington Monument rescue is a nod to
the battle with the titanium man and the
road to civil war comics his eye pieces
glow red just a little to indicate
winnings using his x-ray function and
when he uses his chest drone the drone
camera heads-up display I'm a little a
113 Easter Egg
it's the Cal arts classroom you should
know by now and of course he misses his
chance to recreate the upside-down kiss
from the tobe spider-man
when tomb sees his news footage on the
rescue there's a flash to panic on his
face which we later learn it's because
his daughter Liz was there there's
another clue on the edit here we cut
straight from his face to his wife
hugging Liz in the Midtown news report
behind Jason is a screen showing the
word vision which is actually a nod to
the Brooklyn Vision Academy the high
school that Miles Morales goes to Peter
retrieves his web fluid hidden under the
lockers miss
scratch marks on the wall beside the
locker these are from past times Peter
lifted it
Karen shows Peters recordings notice how
Peters heart rate jumps from 84 to 93
from the shame Erin Davis's rap sheet
lists aliases the Prowler of course and
Brian pinch le a nod to ultimate
spider-man craters Brian Michael Bendis
and Sarah Pitt Shelley with pinch thrown
in there is a thievin pun Erin's license
plate reads UCS mo one for Ultimate
Comics spider-man number one the debut
of Miles Morales whose MCU existence
Erin alludes to here I don't want those
weapons in his neighborhood I got a
nephew living in a deleted scene yes I'm
I'm I'm not gonna make it yeah I'm just
stuck on the ferry we meet Mac Gargan
who has a scorpion neck tattoo for his
identity as a Spidey villain scorpion he
returns in the post-credits scene with
tombs in prison further back on the
ferry our cars tagged in 1920 which
could be a nod to spider-man number 20
when he bites a scorpion the car parked
behind it is tagged
s mo 563 which could be a nod to
spider-man issue 5 released in 1963
which was spider-man's first run-in with
dr. doom and further back on the period
is the long-lost Howard the Duck Easter
Egg that I found HT d oo 350 2015 Howard
the Duck issue 3 which had a variant
cover showing the orange scent Island
Ferry
Peter here uses the esteemed Webb jump
enroll move that cap used on him and
Civil War C Queens is following in
Brooklyn's footsteps he's following his
gut not his head which is what angers
Tony so much the Chitauri text severs
the ferry dementia with things you don't
understand the self-made villain warning
the self-made hero about toys versus
tech lesson that would get reversed
later
Ironman helps repair this with separate
thrusters I love how each one indents
the metal on the ferries hole Tony takes
back the suit this is all I have on
nothing without this chute if you're
nothing without this chute
then you shouldn't have it the one
useful lesson that he learned from Iron
Man 3 see that movie was it unnecessary
to Melissa's dad Wow oh great dramatic
irony here as tooms holds the knife
echoing the tobe spider-man with Osborn
carving the turkey the stop lights red
glow cast tombs and a menacing light and
then
don't spider-man this switch to green
signals the vulture heads-up display is
coming battle armor and the final act
with his date flash mentions branzino
may be a nod to the branzino dinner Cena
the amazing spider-man and happy loads
the plane we just got a load Tony don't
Hulkbuster armor prototype for caps new
shield and the making the make the
floors magic belt the old home Buster
armor was the mark 44 from age of Ultron
but he says old meaning a new one is in
the works which we'll find out is the
mark 48 worn by banner and Infinity Ward
that's new shield is one we don't see
until in-game which replaces the damaged
one in Civil War and Thor's magic belt
is Maegan gourd
it's his belt of strength from Norse
mythology and the Thor comics Peter
confronts tombs but he has not yet
proven himself tombs stalls Peter while
his vultures suit charges to surprise
him which is the same move used by Tony
and Avengers the self-made engineer on
his enemy Loki who at that moment
considered his tech toys Peter panics
trapped under the rubble and then he
sees a reflection of the man without the
suit and he rises reflecting the visual
from the amazing spider-man 33 and he
now fights a villain as the self-made
hero not spoiled by overpowered stark
tech but in the DIY hoodie inspired by
the Ben Riley suit the aerial battle
reflects his transformation with the
cloaking panels in the stark cargo plane
reflecting his new colour scheme as he
crawls on the underside and among the
cargo is Tony's old mark 42 armor from
Iron Man 3 suggesting he'd kept another
model around for I guess sentimental
reasons after the other ones pieces
exploded around Killian tombs jams his
wings into the fuselage raking them
damage that Peter later notices
try to save you the in Civil War Peter
witnessed what happens when a guy gets
stuck in a broken flying suit boom
that's right rody Peters Avengers
training taught him the value of tech
vs. toys and now finally as a self-made
hero he proved himself more worthy over
the scavenger who stole tech and doesn't
fully appreciate it Peter oversees the
arrest atop this cyclone roller coaster
which came up in a memory shared between
cap and Bucky back in cap 1 remember
when I made you ride the cyclone at
Coney Island
yeah and I threw up happy brains Peter
two Avengers HQ repeater where's the
same jokey electron shirt that pepper
worn in Iron Man 3 though he just misses
her here Tony
Iverson the iron spider armor which
Peter will later wear an infinity war
this is based on the armor that Tony
gives him in the Civil War comics as is
the press conference that was about to
happen here but Peter having learned the
lesson as the self-made hero turns him
down realizing that power isn't worth
taking until one is ready for the
responsibility of that power there might
be a better way to phrase that so Peter
stays the one MCU hero who continues to
hide his identity though not from Aunt
May a wine that gets called back as the
final words afar from home when Peter
has this happened in front of the whole
world
Julian our future watch lungs on discord
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash new rock stars we'll wrap up on
the MCU in a few weeks but we plan to
continue weekly watch longs with the new
film series details to come follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at ei vas
following the rockstars and subscribe as
we move on to see how not to treat your
coworkers
[Applause]
[Music]